schon wieder leere regale im supermarkt
bis vor wenigen jahren in deutschland
noch undenkbar jetzt gehört das zum
krisen alltag echte engpässe treffen auf
panische nervige hamsterkäufe aber was
wenn die nächste krise kommt oder der
ukraine krieg sich verschlimmert wir
recherchieren wie wir vorbereitet sind
diese flasche hier die wäre vor ein paar
monaten noch total unscheinbar gewesen
und deutlich günstiger jetzt reißen sich
die leute um sonnenblumenöl assist zum
mangelware geworden der grund der
ukraine krieg die ukraine ist eine der
wichtigsten lieferanten für
sonnenblumenöl menschen in deutschland
müssen jetzt auf bestimmte produkte ganz
verzichten oder viel höhere preise in
kauf nehmen vor ein paar jahren hätten
die meisten wahrscheinlich noch gesagt
unvorstellbar aber eine gruppe von
expertinnen hat schon 2016 davor gewarnt
damals schrieben die forscherinnen und
forscher dass die gefahr von engpässen
unterschätzt wird und dass mögliche
krisenszenarien für viele kaum
vorstellbar seien die
lebensmittelversorgung sei aber durchaus
krisenanfällig und die staatliche
vorsorge nur unzureichend sie sollten
recht behalten eines der szenarien das
die forscher damals untersucht haben das
war eine pandemie wer verstehen will wie
anfällig deutschland für lebensmittel
arbeit ist der sollte sich den
sogenannten selbstversorgungsgrad
anschauen der gibt nämlich an wie viel
prozent der benötigten agrarprodukte im
eigenen land hergestellt werden in
deutschland ist er gerade je nach
produkt sehr unterschiedlich bei
kartoffeln zucker fleisch milch und
getreide liegt er über 100 wir
produzieren also hier theoretisch mehr
als wir brauchen bei anderen produkten
wie beispielsweise gemüse oder obst sind
wir aber stark auf importe angewiesen um
den bundesweiten konsum abzudecken in
anderen ländern da könnte weizen
knappheit zu einem wirklichen problemen
werden zb in pakistan und ägypten in den
beiden ländern daneben zusammengenommen
über 300 millionen menschen die haben
bisher über 80% ihres weizens aus
russland und der ukraine bezogen da
drohen jetzt richtige hungersnöte
deutschland könnte sich dagegen
theoretisch selbst versorgen warum fehlt
es dann trotzdem immer wieder in
deutschen supermärkten an mehl
lebensmittelknappheit kann verschiedene
ursachen haben schauen wir uns also mal
die aktuelle situation an bei weizen
produkten sind russland und die ukraine
zwar wichtige produzenten allerdings ist
deutschland nicht auf importe angewiesen
wenn hier gerade produkte fehlen liegt
das vor allem an hamsterkäufen auch beim
sonnenblumenöl ist es tatsächlich so
dass russland und die ukraine wichtige
produzenten sind hier kann sich
deutschland aber nicht selbst versorgen
der krieg in der ukraine und das embargo
sind hauptverantwortlich für diese
engpässe in zukunft werden dosentomaten
knapp sagen expertinnen und experten
dieser fall ist etwas komplexer die
meisten dosen in deutschland kommen aus
italien
dort steigen die produzentinnen gerade
vermehrt auf den anbau von mais und
getreide um weil das einfach lukrativer
ist denn die dosen die sie kaufen müssen
müssen erst mal hergestellt werden das
kostet energie und die wiederum ist
wegen des kriegs in der ukraine teurer
geworden deutschland geht es also trotz
vereinzelter knappheiten verhältnismäßig
noch ganz gut trotzdem gibt es in der
bevölkerung die angst dass ich das noch
verschlimmern könnte das zeigen ja auch
die hamsterkäufe zu recht wir haben beim
experten henning görtz kirsch
nachgefragt erst katastrophenforscher
und er hat sich schon öfters mit der
ernährungs notfallvorsorge beschäftigt
also die
möglichkeiten die grundszenarien was
ihre lebensmittel kinderpark jetzt
auslösen kann sind relativ vielfältig
wir haben uns einerseits mit dingen zu
tun die so ein bisschen zunächst mal
weicher klingen die weltwirtschaft aber
ihr ist das ganze system eigentlich auch
tatsächlich relativ anfällig was ist ein
bereich und dann natürlich so ein
bisschen härtere szenarien das ist dann
eben ganz konkret krieg oder cyber
angriffe der ganze bereich kritische
infrastrukturen bis hin zu
naturkatastrophen
und solchen szenarien des klimawandels
viele sachen sind denkbar ob das jetzt
im nächsten wochen da monaten deutlich
schlimmer wird lässt sich deshalb auch
weil es eben so komplexes relativ schwer
sagen also sollte sich schon deutlich
sein dass temporäre ausfälle bei
bestimmten produkten bestimmte extreme
verteuerungen bei bestimmten produkten
doch durchaus im bereich des
wahrscheinlichen sind die angst vor
einer lebensmittelknappheit die kann man
natürlich auch am verhalten der menschen
sehen während die einen in die
supermärkte rennen und hamster gehen die
anderen noch viel weiter philipp nato
hat einen shop für notfallvorräte da
kostet dann das family paket für vier
personen 30 tage 1200 euro und seit
beginnen das ukraine kriegs ist die
nachfrage wirklich riesig seit
kriegsbeginn hat sich eine weitere welle
wir hatten einfach minütlich
bestellungen so dass wir so ein berg von
bestellungen hatten und wenn wir die
ganzen tag abgearbeitet hatten abends um
18 uhr das immer noch so alles das war
schon sehr glücklich mir ihre angebote
angeschaut also das klassische
familienpaket das kostet über 1000 euro
und die komplettlösung die kosten mehr
als 17.000 euro das muss man sich ja
schon auch leisten können natürlich in
absoluten zahlen ist es stimmt dass
bestimmt das schon aber wir machen
ordnungsmittel longboard das heißt die
banken die unter schutzatmosphäre ob die
sind dann auch mindestens zehn jahre
halten jedem vergleich thema machen will
mit einem supermarkt das ist zwei jahre
ist das einmal dabei zwei jahren da muss
man den betrieb immer für fünf wochen um
auf die zehn jahre kommen nach senden
die ängste ihrer kundschaft das ungewiss
ist was kommt und das habe ich weiß auch
nicht was kommt ich möchte so
vorbereitet sein dass es mir auch ein
bisschen egal ist auch die regierung rät
übrigens dazu private vorräte anzulegen
dafür wurde extra diese tabelle erstellt
da geht es darum dass eine person zehn
tage durchhält mit diesen produkten
vollkornbrot 714 kann sauerkraut 500
kann trockenfleisch
179 gramm mineralwasser 20 litern
dauerwurst
257 speiseöl zb rapsöl 0,2 1 4 litern es
gibt auch extra eine vegetarische
tabelle bei der ersatzprodukte für
fleisch und fisch vorgeschlagen werden
privat vorräte anlegen ist das sinnvoll
oder ist das panik machen private
notfallvorräte sind in jedem fall sehr
sinnvoll weil sie in einer ganzen reihe
von szenarien einfach ihre wirkung
entfalten können ideal ist es zum
beispiel jedem einkauf ein wenig
mitzunehmen für den vorrat und dem sich
über einen gewissen zeitraum
aufzustocken und solche dinge wie nudeln
reis und ähnliches die sind auch über
das mindesthaltbarkeitsdatum sehr lange
haltbar da brauche ich jetzt einige
nicht spezielle produkte von besonderen
anbietern ein wichtiger bestandteil von
der staatlichen notfallvorsorge sind die
staatlichen nahrungsreserven
niemand weiß wo diese lebensmittel
liegen es gibt nur dieses video material
aus den lagern das uns zur verfügung
gestellt wurde tausende säcke an
lebensmitteln für den notfall doch wie
viele lebensmittel werden vom staat
eigentlich gelagert laut
landwirtschaftsministerium gibt es
folgende vorräte
56.000 tonnen hafer
67.000 tonnen roggen
582.000 tonnen weichweizen 5000 tonnen
kondensmilch 18.000 tonnen linsen 83.000
tonnen reis 23.000 tonnen erbsen wie
viele menschen diese reserven jetzt
reichen das möchte das ministerium nicht
so genau sagen interne berechnungen
werden nicht rausgegeben diese vorräte
sind nur für kurzfristige engpässe
gedacht sie sprechen da von mehreren
tagen oder mehreren wochen je nach
szenario jetzt will man sich das konzept
noch mal genauer anschauen es gibt aber
auch noch ein weiteres instrument das
der regierung ermöglichen würde als
letztes mittel sehr weiter einzugreifen
nämlich das ernährungs sicherstellung
und vorsorgen gesetz mit diesem gesetz
kann der staat sogar in die produktion
eingreifen also im grunde wenn ich jetzt
mal versucht ein bisschen drastisch
dazustellen können wir damit relativ auf
knopfdruck dann von einer
marktwirtschaft in eine planwirtschaft
wechseln das heißt also das ministerium
ist dann ermächtigt zu sagen was wird
produziert wie viel wieder vom
produziert in welchen nach welchen
preisen wie das ausgegeben oder wie wird
es überhaupt ausgegeben wie wird es
verteilt klingt allerdings auch im
gesetz das natürlich so schnell wie
möglich der das sozusagen zurückgedreht
werden soll zum ursprünglichen zustand
das so zu sagen dass der markt wieder
greift das für mich auch eine weitere
stufe der der staatlichen vorsorge im
ernährungsbereich dann zu sagen ja die
leute meinen hunger wir müssen jetzt
einfach das was da ist verteilen und das
so produzieren dass es gut verteilter
ist dass die menschen einfach satt
werden letztlich ein szenario das
ehrlich gesagt heute realistischer
erscheint als noch vor ein paar monaten
der krieg in der ukraine hat uns gezeigt
wie schnell ereignisse eintreten können
die erstmal für unwahrscheinlich
gehalten werden wie ist der staat
generell vorbereitet auf krisen
katastrophen
reichen die staatlichen maßnahmen in
unserer neuen folge die spuren zeigen
wir wie menschen sich privat bunker und
vorräte an weil sie angst vor einem
krieg haben global die ängste nehmen
schon zu und wir sprechen mit
verantwortlichen aus der politik
natürlich gibt es für solche fälle
katastrophenschutzpläne dafür sind wir
in deutschland ab vorbereitet
also so richtig vertrauen würde ich
nicht darauf dass so ein dokument nur
weil es im plan vorhanden ist dann auch
tatsächlich praktisch gelebt wird
die doku findet ihr jetzt in der zdf
mediathek
[Musik]